the collective Hive algorithm has yet to
quote pick up the pheromonal signature
of what we're putting down so from a
quote like a mathematics or artificial
intelligence computer science
perspective even biology what's being
said is that what we're pointing to is a
global maximum whereas right now we're
stuck at a local maximum you see so the
little anive or beehive of the
collective is like circling for food and
resources around the local maximum and
what we're doing through our content
through our new Earth portal is we're
generating Catalyst at that local
maximum to then create the Alchemy the
transformation for the bees and the Ants
aka the humans to start moving more and
more towards holy look at this
Global
maximum but it takes energy it takes
resources it takes alignment it takes
death it takes death of the local Max
maximum to move to the global maximum
you have to completely detach from all
of those Matrix Systems from all of the
uh you have to sell your your your time
for money to pay for your basic needs
you have to you have to detach
completely from all of those things see
that they served very good very good but
now we're moving on to this Global
maximum and it's this
constitutionalization into an allocation
of energy and resource and everything
into that Global maximum and so that's
how say it from a CS aai mathematics bio
perspective that's you know it's really
relevant for us Geeks like I'm a geek
like I'm a nerd I'm a dork 100% so you
know I relate to you science and
engineering peep so deeply I've
interviewed hundreds and
hundreds of you in all of your different
fields and so um this is this is my way
of communicating to you with love that
we need you fam we need
you we need you you are our new Earth
Systems Engineers you are incredibly
brilliant Geniuses but you're still not
polarizing you're still not fully
aligning into that and this is what
we're opening up through our our new
Earth portal we're opening up we're
opening up for you the ability to align
into that and to activate your own gifts
for that